♪ No one told me about her ♪
♪ What could I do? ♪
♪ Well, no one told me about her ♪
♪ Though they all knew ♪
♪ But it's too late to say you're sorry ♪
♪ How would I know? ♪
♪ Why should I care? ♪
♪ Please don't bother trying to find her ♪
♪ She's not there ♪
♪ Well, let me tell you
'bout the way she looked ♪
♪ The way she acted and
the color of her hair ♪
♪ Her voice was soft and cool ♪
♪ Her eyes were clear and bright ♪
♪ But she's not there ♪
♪ Well, no one told me about her ♪
♪ What could I do ♪
(laughing)
♪ But it's too late to say I'm sorry ♪
♪ How would I know ♪
♪ Why should I care ♪
♪ Please don't bother trying to find her ♪
♪ She's not there ♪
♪ Well, I can tell you
about the way she looks ♪
♪ The way she acted and
the color of her hair ♪
♪ Her voice was soft and cool ♪
♪ Her eyes were clear and bright ♪
♪ But she's not there ♪
♪ I smell blossom and the trees are bare ♪
♪ All day long I seem to walk on air ♪
(laughing)
♪ I wonder why ♪
- You join in, you two.
- No, no, no, I don't sing, I don't sing.
- Oh, turn it up.
Turn it up, I love this song.
- Want it louder?
- All the way.
(upbeat, band music)
- Colin, wild cracker.
Tell him, I thought I'm fine.
(upbeat dance mucic)
- [Woman] Do we have one more chair?
- Happiness is a fickle creature.
Constant companion to some,
hides herself completely from others.
She's been an elusive creature to me.
But, here she is,
finally, sitting among us,
and I say, welcome.
I won't mention how later her arrival is.
- Who?
- Hmm?
Happiness, dear.
Oh, nevermind.
- [Man] Yes sir, no problem, right.
- Cream?
- I'm not burning, am I?
- Not yet.
Better safe than sorry.
(camera shutter clicking)
(ominous music)